welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division is giving viewers
theory whiplash
in the wake of quicksilver evan peters
whiplash
the character we assumed was smoking gun
confirmation of fox x-men crossing over
into the mcu
until episode six answered zero
questions about the x-men and instead
made this pietro a creepy weirdo who
either knows too much or too little
so is evan peters pantro x-men
quicksilver or not
if he is how the hell will wandavision
explain that
and if he's not if he is just a disguise
for the real big bad
then why did marvel cast evan peters
a guy best known for playing silver in
another franchise
in this role what are they playing at
why is gamora and how upset should aaron
taylor johnson be
well not why is gamora no one will ever
know sorry drax
okay the moment evan peters pietro
arrived audience surrogate darcy
encapsulated our confusion with this
question
she recast pietro acknowledging that the
whole mcu does not have facial blindness
as they did with bruce banner and rhodey
but rather
pietro maximoff in the mcu is supposed
to be aaron taylor johnson and that evan
peters
is an intrusive replacement so was evan
peters pietro
plucked from a fox x-men reality within
a multiverse that the mcu is now
merging with well pietro's final line in
episode 5 began to clue us into what's
going on here who's a popsicle yes
notice that he is not weirded out by
seeing vision as vision something that
they have kept from everyone else within
the westview anomaly and instead of this
guy
nose vision should be a cold lifeless
corpse
already we're seeing how this pietro is
not part of the west view hex but more
importantly it tells us that this pietro
cannot be the aaron taylor johnson
pietro recast
because he died in age of ultron that
was three years before
vision died in infinity war and episode
six double down on pietro's impossible
omniscience with his joke about vision's
death don't sweat it sis
it's not like your dead husband can die
twice
meanwhile when this pietro is asked
about his past he recalls a history
completely removed from anything we saw
evan peters quicksilver go through in
the fox x-men franchise but rather a
kind of spotty recollection of aaron
taylor johnson's history
details are fuzzy man i got shot like a
chump in the street for no reason at all
and next thing i know
i heard you calling me but the problem
here is aaron taylor johnson pietro
would not have described his death as
being
shot like a chump in the street for no
reason he used himself as a human shield
to save the life of hawkeye and that
sokovian kid so
this description sounds like it's coming
from an outside observer who doesn't
give a [ __ ] about human life so we know
that this evan peters pietro is not the
fox x-men quicksilver but he's also
not a simple recast to the ucu aaron
taylor johnson pietro he is something
else
someone with the goal of making wanda
feel pain i'm just trying to do my part
okay come to town unexpectedly create
tension with the brother-in-laws draw up
trouble with the rugrats and ultimately
give you grief
i mean that's what you wanted isn't it
and you remember the episode 6 opening
credits also
cast pietro weirdly as himself and the
recent funko pop release put his name in
quotes so based on all this i had made
the case that evan peters pietro is a
kind of halloween costume disguised for
the
true dark entity trying to exploit wanda
either
the marvel villain nightmare based on a
few of those nightmare mentions this
episode we take her out this whole
nightmare ends it's a pretty big leap
from giving people nightmares and
shooting red wiggly woos out your hands
or mephisto based on the demonic
references in the series the devil's in
the details bev
that's not the only place he is unleash
hell demon spawn
dammit if westview new jersey isn't
charming as hell but still
why evan peters though why are they
confusing us like this you know i
shouldn't be so critical of these
characters i don't have very good
financial credit myself building my
credit score is up there with learning
how to parallel park and avoiding
ketchup stains has some of the biggest
lessons we all have to learn as we grow
up well
petal is here to help with the with the
credit one pedal is a credit card
company that wants to help you succeed
financially
that's why the pedal one card is
designed to help you build
credit when you apply for pedal one your
banking history is used to instantly
create a cash score it could help you
qualify for a better credit card even if
you've never had a credit score before
the pedal one visa card has no
annual fee or international transaction
fees their app comes with some amazing
features it lets you link your other
financial accounts so that you can see
everything in one place and you can see
if you're pre-approved without
impacting your credit score and it only
takes minutes to apply online pedal one
is partnered with web bank member fdic
which issues the cards as of today the
pedal one variable aprs range from 19.99
to 29.49
start building your credit history go to
petalcar.com
new rockstars today to find out more
that's petal with a t
petal p-e-t-a-l-card.com
new rockstars well here's the deal i
believe the wanda vision team is trying
to give
fans some fun fan service but they have
not realized how much fans would
interpret this
as a concrete crossover but i'm gonna
ask all of you to cool your jets right
now biggest think if this were an
actual x-men mcu crossover think about
what that would mean for kevin feige
feige would suddenly be responsible for
every plot point from those fox x-men
films
some parts like evan peters quick silver
scenes are great
but move one degree of separation
outward and suddenly feige has to start
answering
questions like which x-men are the real
ones
why does time travel work differently is
everyone mistake
why do all of them never age and of
course how dare you cross over
quicksilver and deadpool but not the
true star of this franchise vinnie
joseph juggernaut i'm the juggernaut
[ __ ] all of the new young fans who from
here forward subscribe to disney plus
and see
x-men quicksilver in one division and
then go watch the
fox titles that are also on that
streaming service knowing nothing about
release dates or
past eras being separate ip franchises
would assume
x-men apocalypse and x-men dark phoenix
are part of kevin feige's mcu
and to that i'm gonna do my best kevin
feige here no [ __ ] way
this guy won't even acknowledge agents
of shield and agent carter as mcu cannon
despite those series having these same
actors
and working their asses off to fit into
the mcu movie timeline
still they aren't good enough for him
kevin feige worked as an associate
producer on the first x-men he cares
deeply about the x-men brand but he
is way too proud of his mcu infinity
saga to sully it with a mixed bag of
movies that he had nothing to do with
now
sure sure it is entirely possible that
the one division team has a secret
in-universe explanation for how
quicksilver could have crossed the
multiverse to get here
maybe as a speedster only he could break
through the barrier of time and space
into a new timeline
flashpoint paradox or maybe the big bad
of this series watches over these
separate film franchises like mojo
and is capable of plucking a quick
silver from one universe and dragging it
into another one
yeah yeah you feel that reach burns
doesn't it that's because
if this insanity has to be explained by
darcy or scrawled on jimmy woo's dry
erase board
way more people are going to be confused
and disappointed than if evan peter's
cameo is revealed to be something much
simpler a meta nod to fans
an ironic cameo little cameo just to
tease that marvel studios has
access to the x-men but is not yet
building a complete concrete bridge to a
franchise that they don't really need
or really want to merge with now sure
marvel may have
underestimated how much evan peters
would melt the brain to the core fan
base or how much casual viewers would
take their cues from our gut reactions
thanks for watching by the way but evan
peters could be as simple as
a stunt casted walk-on roll that fans
identify as
humorously out of place soon to be
revealed as
either a disguise worn by a villain or a
projection of wanda's own subconscious
but either way
a temporary red herring one that won't
last beyond the series and one that will
not erase the legacy of aaron taylor
johnson who remains the true pietro
maximoff of the mcu hey you can continue
this nerdy conversation on new
rockstar's official discord server by
becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars you can also
support us by checking out some of our
great merch options including this shirt
an unusual couple
at newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for all of your one division
questions thank you for watching
[Music]
you